[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with Moya Logan McLean and
Annabelle Denham so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now or
the front of the eye analyzes the first
day of the Conservative Party Conference
their headline Tory Rebellion bills
against defiant pm
Tories threaten Rebellion as Gove says
tax plan is not conservative reads the
front of the Guardian as they also look
at tensions within the conservative
party
the Metro also looks at the former
cabinet minister Michael gove's comments
gov and Schatz attack tineard Tory tax
cuts reads the front of the times as
they also look at critiques of the
conservative party
and the front of the Daily Telegraph
looks at the prime minister's response
with the headline trust delays vote on
45p tax cut after Tory revolt
Fury as go Stokes Tory 45p tax revolt
with the front of the Daily Mail as they
also lead with this story
and in other news The Daily Star looks
at the potential mental health benefits
of burgers
quite a different story a reminder that
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and we are
joined tonight by moyolovia McLean and
Annabelle Denham welcome to both of you
let's take a look at the Metro uh first
of all actually all the papers we'll be
covering in the first half looking at
the Conservative Party Conference but
the Metro the headline go this isn't
Tori which he's suggesting that the
modes deployed to tackle the economy by
the Prime Minister are simply not
conservative enough
well I don't think it's the not
conservative enough what Michael Gove is
saying here is he's actually come out
brutally criticized Liz trusts and
quasi-kartang's proposed tax plans he
says it's very very difficult to argue
for reducing welfare to pay for a tax
cut for the richest and he's saying it's
not conservative isn't that the essence
of what he's saying it's not you yeah
but he's not saying it's not
conservative enough he's saying it's not
conservative is it a Capital C
conservative so he's saying the use of
using borrowed money to fund tax cuts is
not conservative with a Capital C and
then he's saying the decision to cut the
top rate of tax for the top earners in
this country
um at a time when people are suffering
is completely wrong and he's also said
he will vote against this plan he's just
one of two high-profile Tories that have
come out at the start of the Tory
conference in order to oppose these tax
plans with Grant chaps the former
transport Minister slamming these Cuts
richest as tin Aid in the times today
and these Cuts would give one billion
pounds to to 200 2 500 of British
Britain's richest individuals which is
about an average of 400 000 pounds each
meanwhile while cutting benefits for the
poorest level to pay for
yes Annabelle that's exactly uh what
he's saying he's criticized that a
number of mistakes in fact uh the plan
to grow the economy by borrowing 45
billion as we've said um the sheer risk
of using borrowed money to fund tax cuts
and the decision to cut the 45p rate as
the specifics
but I mean it's not altogether
surprising that Michael Gove has come
out against these policies and let's not
forget that back in August when he
announced uh his departure from
Frontline politics that he accused Liz
truss of being on a holiday from reality
so this sort of intervention was perhaps
to be expected I suppose the cover of
the Metro really begs the question what
is Tori
um and it's quite interesting that the
former cabinet minister who was a
cabinet minister for 11 years and served
on the three prime ministers so it
really says something that he didn't
feel that he was able to
um support this one
um but really what I would say was the
least Tory part of the mini budget was
actually the energy price guarantee this
is
um going to cost possibly um far north
of 100 billion pounds depending on what
um happens to energy prices
um so it's going to be you know it's
extraordinary uh intervention that will
prevent Market forces from from working
so in some ways it's quite surprising
that he's take an object an issue with
the 45p additional rate of income tax
being abolished but it hasn't really
said anything about the energy price
guarantee yes and that's something that
many have said if they just focused on
um actually they wouldn't have been all
of the Fallout that we've seen over the
last week let's move on to the guardian
Moya and they're suggesting that this
trust is struggling to to win over
conservative MPS that Rebellion is uh in
the offing and that's that's the threat
that she's facing as conference uh
season starts for her
yeah well in just about three weeks of
Liz trust taking over she's managed
she's only been able to make political
decisions for two weeks because of the
death of Queen Elizabeth and in those
two weeks the pound has crashed the bank
of England has had to intervene to bail
out pensions and the Tory party ratings
among the electric have absolutely
tanked that is the reason they ousted
Boris Johnson in the first place and now
Liz truss has managed to give labor in
some places a 33 point lead so it's no
surprise that there's already Rebellion
Brewing
um we heard last week that letters of no
confidence may be already sending in and
now they're saying we won't vote in
favor of this 45 P the 45
um top-rate tax card
um so I think we'll get on to this a
minute but there's this is now posing a
problem so much that the vote will be
moved potentially
yes that that is uh being covered this
evening but Annabelle we read that we'll
hear from the chancellor tomorrow but
he's going to pledge to to stay the
course
well yes I mean I think at u-turn at
this point could be potentially quite
disastrous not just for Liz truss's uh
Premiership but also for the country
um you know I think that um the vessel
is is listing and this would put many
more holes in it and leads it to sink so
I think the government is ultimately
right to be staying the course and as
Liz truss conceded this morning it's
really been an issue primarily of
presentation and communication not just
with the British public but of course
little effort went into trying to calm
the markets which themselves can be
highly volatile so this sort of reaction
um you know some ought to have really
seen it coming and the chancellor ought
to have uh tried to calm them to ensure
that we didn't have a near break the
breakdown in financial stability that we
saw mid-week with the bank of England
having to step in um to help uh Pension
funds by buying government bonds so yes
I think the the Liz trust and the
chancellor have recognized that they've
obviously made these pretty fundamental
errors and are now trying to correct
that in order that they may be able to
push through some of these measures what
did you make of what's been described as
the Prime Minister throwing the
chancellor under the the bus saying that
he went ahead with this top rate of a
tax cut
um and not acknowledging that actually
she would have had to give him the say
so
I think it's highly predictable that in
uh when both of them are now receiving
so much Flack for these terrible
decisions that people are stepping away
I think it's also important to note that
Annabelle is actually the director of
communications from The Institute of
economic Affairs which is the think tank
that has been pushing these exact
policies and ideas and is very closely
tied to Liz truss and quasi-quartang
throughout so it makes it's not a
surprise to me that Annabelle is saying
here we should stay the cause because
these the policies the iea and other
think tanks on tufton Street have been
amplifying and encouraging Tory
governments to implement for years and
years and years now they finally have
been implemented what we've seen is the
markets respond as people predicted
they've crashed they didn't like it that
maybe that's the freest Market of them
all they've rejected it but um it makes
it doesn't surprise me at all that Liz
truss is now trying to withdraw from
some of the political Flack and make
sure that her Chancellor potentially
takes the fall she is a Survivor she has
survived this long in politics and she
is known for flip-flopping on positions
so if we get a U-turn that also wouldn't
surprise me either but I hope we do for
the sake of the people in the country
that will be most affected by these
massively unequal new measures
and Annabelle the Institute of economic
Affairs um the role is to kind of
explain markets in solving economic uh
and social problems and in that respect
do you believe that really there is no
room for um a U-turn in terms of a
policy direction that the chancellor and
the Prime Minister need to continue
along this route
well look guys I mean obviously The
Institute of economic Affair is Affairs
is a free market Think Tank and why is
absolutely right that we have advocated
for some of these uh policies and
haven't been doing so since we were
founded back in 1965.
um look we've got the tax burden at the
highest level that it's been in seven
decades you know a lot of people were
against the hike in National Insurance
contributions that came in uh earlier
this year in which Liz trust has
reversed in a lot of economists across
the Spectrum were opposed to the
corporation tax rise this isn't purely
the sorts of measures that the Institute
of economic Affairs was uh proposing but
no that's absolutely right and it's
frustrating in some ways really that
there's been so much focus on this 45 5p
additional rates of income tax given
that it's going to cost um very little
in fact by some estimates it may not uh
cost anything at all um you know we need
so just just to clarify what is the Ia
position on that then
I well I can't speak for the iea's
position on on any measure the gut or
policy the government might be
introducing but my own view is that it's
uh absolutely right to be um looking to
uh cut to the 45p rate of uh income tax
additional rate of income tax and let's
not forget that it was 40p under labor
government there's actually a coalition
government that brought in higher rate
uh back in 2010 so we're only taking
ourselves back to where we were at 12
years ago like I said it's relatively uh
inexpensive pretty trivial when you
compare it to the massive cost of the
energy price uh guarantee and the idea
behind cutting it is that it should
stimulate investment it should
incentivize people
um to work and we also you do have the
problem that since 2010 the threshold
hasn't been adjusted if it had been
adjusted in line with inflation then
today the threshold wouldn't be 150 000
pounds uh salary it would be 215 000
pounds and I'm just not very comfortable
with go our successive governments just
increasingly pushing more and more
people into the higher rates of of tax
okay but it raises about six billion
pounds so that top rate of tax rate is
about six billion pounds and it's paid
by only half a million people some of
the richest in the country and the idea
that these tax cuts are benefiting
everyone and that the and the comparison
of the energy price freeze which isn't
really a price freeze at all it just
means some people on average will only
pay two a thousand five hundred pounds
they still can go higher than that
comparing that as a big spending measure
that's designed to try and save people
from Energy prices that could absolutely
ruin households to to this tax cut for
the very rich in the country they're
just not equivocal things at all okay
Moya and Annabelle I think you've had
equal time on that on this particular
story we must go to the break uh coming
up a look at this story on the front of
the times their headline of pollution
threat to go nuclear may not be a blast
that's the US do stay with us for me
[Music]
foreign
still with me contributing editor at
Novara media Moya Lothian McLean and
director of communications at The
Institute of economic Affairs Annabelle
Denham welcome back to both of you let's
um have a look at this story on the
front page of the Telegraph and that is
the hospitals are scrapping more than 22
000 appointments every day uh the
average number of daily cancellations
this year is up 20 on pre-pandemic
figures when they're about 18 000 every
day so that the problem
um getting much much worse Moira
yeah so this is the NHS backlog which is
basically since the pandemic the NHS has
been in further crisis it was an
important condition going into the
pandemic and coming out of it uh various
political upheaval the lack of actually
resourcing the NHS the NHS is funded but
it's not resourced has meant that
patients are suffering and we're seeing
that everywhere from urgent care to NHS
Dentistry so at the moment
um 22 000 appointments have been
canceled every day last week the new
health secretary Teresa coffee set out
her new plan for patients but there's
about 6.8 million patients currently
waiting to start treatment and it's
becoming quite obvious that the paper
and over of the cracks is no longer
working the burnout of Staff within the
NHS Healthcare from Healthcare staff to
cleaners is a huge rate means that new
people aren't coming in because the
training isn't there and meanwhile
patients are suffering we're seeing
deaths from cancer go out we're seeing
deaths from treatable diseases increase
so this is a problem that this trust's
Administration will have to deal with
head-on but because the economy is in
such turmoil that hasn't even really
been starting to be tackled and we're
not seeing whether new money will be
coming from to actually really confront
this problem more than just the plan for
patients that has already been announced
yes and more than the figures is that
the story of real people Kathleen
lipinski's mentioned here 65 from
Welling Garden City uh broke down in
tears after her cancer scam was canceled
for the second time this summer The
retired social worker whose skin cancer
underwent two weeks of radiotherapy and
needed a positive emission tomography
scan to determine if the treatment had
worked
um so that the real story of uh how
people are affected the actual real
lives of of people and for time we're
going to move on to the times uh
Annabelle and this story that Putin's
threat to news nuclear weapons uh may
not be a threat it may not be a bluff
that's coming from the United States a
real real concern
yes it is absolutely when perhaps when
it comes from the Kremlin you're not
sure if this is just nuclear saber
rattling but when it's coming from the
American defense secretary it can it
sends chills down the back of your spine
doesn't it you know this this is uh what
we've all
um feared and you know we talked about
and the article talks about this nuclear
cerebral it's rattling but of course I
can remember when we were talking about
Computing saber rattling just before he
sent tanks across the border and now
that uh the Russian president is really
backed into a corner I think there's a
question to be asked well who who knows
what he might do next now it's possible
that he is uh threatening and
frightening uh the West
um because he's trying to test our
resolve of course he's choking off
energy supplies just as we go into
winter and I think it it the West's
commitment to the war in Ukraine over
the next next six months is going to be
uh tested uh enormously
um and the challenge will be um for us
to continue to support Ukraine by
providing military assistance and
imposing those sanctions on Russia
um but you know what it remains to be
seen what will happen over the next few
months but this is of course you know
very alarming uh headline to be reading
indeed uh more we've only got about 30
seconds but it is very sobering coming
from the United States isn't it
yes it is
anything else that that time story picks
up on is that the United U.S uh defense
Intel says that Putin is not likely to
use nuclear power straight away it's
more likely that a Cyber attack or cyber
sabotage would hit Europe first to
attack critical infrastructure so once
again I do think this is the United
States trying to make sure that people
aren't just becoming complacent or
hedging their bets and they're warning
against every possible outcome the time
thank you very much